San Francisco the sh hole of San
Francisco the woke disastrous uh City
Once once great City even 10 years ago
known as San Francisco uh the city
council voted 8 to3 uh to call for an
end to this war and a ceasefire and look
at these I may have to show you this
video twice because you really need to
focus in on these
[Applause]
people
I just want everyone to look at it again
can I speak over this one too just look
at each one of these people every one of
these people would be thrown off a
building look at this freak and this
Weirdo And that gender queer nut bag
these people would all be killed by the
people that they are celebrating Emily
irony is truly dead is it
not first that baby we need to call
Child Protective Services to remove that
baby from this I'm going to assume
that's a Woman by the way she looks as
soon as possible B I really think that
this um little party that they just
threw has in fact freed Palestine so I
want to congratulate San Francisco for
being the first city in the United
States to free Palestine lastly did they
make sure to call BB and Hamas and
demand a ceasefire now because they seem
like they're celebrating that they've
accomplished something so I'd like to
know what in fact they accomplished Ari
what is it about progressives that they
can watch their own cities crumbling I
mean that's what's happening in San
Francisco and Chicago and New York in
Portland and Seattle and they spend more
time doing these ridiculous hearings
while while they literally have drugs
everywhere crime's rampant you can't
park your car on the street and the rest
of it like the disconnect between their
own lives and what they think they're
doing 7,000 mil away is
extraordinary well I think when you're
in that kind of mind space you're trying
to probably fill the void of meaning in
any kind of way that you can and for a
lot of conservatives in America I mean
we have religion and so we're focusing
on religion on Family Life whereas for a
lot of progressives that have taken more
of the Enlightenment route and walked
away from religion and a lot of them
which are atheists I mean when you live
like that you need to fill the void and
so they're going towards politics
they're going towards movements that are
constantly changing from one to another
because it would be kind of boring to
just believe the same exact thing and
spend a whole year talking about
something instead of having a current
thing that rolls out on a monthly basis
and so this is the current thing this is
exactly what they're doing they want to
participate in it it gives them meaning
uh it's completely wrong but that's
where I think it's coming from yeah well
said the
go said I think the reason most woke
people are atheists is because believing
in God means you have a belief that
something's above you something's more
powerful than you and bigger than you
and this woke mob they are so
narcissistic that they need to make
everything about them why is everything
insulting to them why are their feelings
hurt and they're too narcissistic to
believe that anything could be more
important than them including God just
shows you how insane they
are